eeuu se enfrenta a un fuerte incremento
de contagios de kobe 19 con más de
100.000 contagios diarios el país ha
llegado al máximo visto hace seis meses
el motivo la virulenta variante delta y
el estancamiento de las vacunaciones
entre los más afectados se encuentran
los estados del sur una combinación de
donde tienen una gran cantidad de la
variante delta y una baja cobertura de
vacunación donde tengamos una vacunación
baja veremos un aumento pronunciado
medios afortunadamente las escuelas van
a ser un acelerador porque muchos más
niños y personal no vacunado también se
contagiarán
repunte está afectando especialmente a
los estados sureños donde las tasas de
inoculación son más bajas
florida epicentro del repunte ya cuenta
con más de 12 mil hospitalizaciones por
kobe 19 y anthony fault si el principal
experto en enfermedades infecciosas del
país afirmó que los casos podrían llegar
a los 200 mil diarios en las próximas
semanas sin embargo con la reapertura la
mayoría de los estados han dejado en
manos de las escuelas locales la
decisión de exigir mascarillas hacer
doble asiento real
molesta por no haber tenido una opción
segura me siento realmente disgustada de
que a pesar de que el gobierno del
condado de gente haya establecido el
mandato de las mascarillas para sus
edificios públicos los niños queden
fuera de todas estas medidas de
seguridad en la última semana eeuu
reportó un aumento del 48% de los
positivos respecto al anterior ante el
incremento derivado de la variante de
alta la casa blanca planea ofrecer
inyecciones de refuerzo a la población
más vulnerable